okay there's a really really weird and
by weird I mean just more lies by the
Trump family a situation related to the
death of Lee David Johnson and if you
have not been following this story
Myesha johnson is the widow of 'la david
johnson 'la david johnson was a service
member killed in Nazaire and she had a
phone call with donald trump last week
which I talked to you about in one of
our programs from Las Vegas and as she
told the story Donald Trump got on the
phone with her and exhibited a total
lack of empathy and allegedly also said
to her her husband knew what he signed
up for which could not be a more callous
and unex tate 'men tap resident could
make and the controversy afterwards has
been well what was said what wasn't said
and one of the ways we could figure out
whether Donald Trump was the totally
unethical to review a transcript of this
phone call now it just so happens that
lara trump who is the wife of Eric trump
who doesn't work for the White House and
Eric Trump also doesn't work for the
White House lera Trump certainly doesn't
work work there
she says she read a transcript of the
phone call he or she is being
interviewed on Fox News by Fox News's
Amy era Ainsley Earhardt
take a listen to this conversation
here's the president United States
calling it express his condolences on
behalf of the incredibly grateful nation
and people turn into a political item
and to me it's disgusting you read the
transcripts what robots from what I've
seen this is just a clear case of the
media not doing their job whenever you
read exactly what he said he said your
husband went into battle you know
knowing that he could be injured knowing
that he could be killed and he still did
it because he loves this country yeah so
Ainsley Earhardt says you read the
transcripts and she says when you read
exactly what was said so if she didn't
read the transcript she's certainly not
making any indication that that's the
case so question one is why would Larry
Trump be reading transcript
if they haven't been released publicly
because again she has no role in the
white house whatsoever but question 2
which is the bigger question is how did
she read a transcript that supposedly
does not exist wait wait a second
what yes during a recent press
conference the White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders said in
no uncertain terms there is no such
transcript here she is there's not a
transcript of the call I believe she was
responding to reports and things that
she had read but I haven't spoken
directly with her I'd refer you to the
campaign that handles her press
inquiries there's not a transcript if
indeed Lara Trump was talking about
things that she read publicly why did
Fox News his Ainsley Earhardt asked
seemingly knowingly about the transcript
that she believed Larry Trump had read
and why didn't Lera Trump nor Eric Trump
say oh no we actually didn't read a
transcript we don't even know whether
there is a transcript so once again
someone here is lying and we get back to
the question of why the transcript is
relevant well it would tell us exactly
what Donald Trump said if this call is
sacred as we've heard then why does Lera
Trump get to see the transcript she
doesn't even have a totally made-up and
fabricated White House position like
Ivanka Trump does at least go through
the trouble of creating one for her
unless you consider Lera Trump actually
does some kind of video show about all
the great things and wonderful things
that Donald Trump has done but again we
have to go to our political Occam's
razor what is most likely what's the
simplest explanation that there is a
transcript and that lara trump did read
it despite no one else reading it and
it's as bad as we've heard Trump is
totally on empathy akin the phone call
or that she was confused but worse for
some reason neither she nor Eric Trump
nor Ainsley Earhardt addressed the fact
that there actually wasn't this
transcript that they claimed they
actually read no the simplest
explanation
there's a transcript and they've read it
and nobody else has but I want to try to
focus on the really relevant stuff
because the Trump administration and
their associates lying and their family
members lying is not really news anymore
that's kind of the default the Trump
administration did nothing about the
ambush and I share where all of these
soldiers were killed until the media
realized that Trump was totally m.i.a on
the issue for all the allegations
against so suppose it fake news media
and they're making up of stories that we
hear from Trump we needed the media to
actually try to get some semblance of
accountability from the Trump
administration on this story the White
House drafted a Nazaire sympathy
statement for Donald Trump which was
never released or read it wasn't until
two weeks later that the president who's
on Twitter all the time he's tweeting
about all sorts of nonsense all the time
finally mentioned the deaths of these
soldiers in me share when he was asked
about them during an impromptu news
conference on on Monday the 16th in the
White House rose garden I can't believe
I am saying this but I am sick and tired
of the President of the United States
regularly and seemingly with deliberate
indifference disrespecting the military
service members of the United States the
right like to say it's the left that
doesn't support the troops but I've seen
I've not seen this level of disrespect
and indifference to the military from a
president for a very very long time
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
re d di t today's program is made
possible in part by zip recruiter if you
are hiring if you're looking to hire
somebody you need to know where to post
the job to find the best candidates and
zip recruiter makes hiring easier it
makes hiring more streamlined and also
less time-consuming if you're hiring you
know that there are a variety of
difficulties that can come up and
finding the right people and with zip
recruiter you can post your job to one
hundred-plus job sites with one click
you can use the zip recruiter dashboard
to evaluate rate and
follow up with applicants ultimately
finding the best suited applicant for
the job but also zip recruiter will find
good applicants for your job they have
what's called smart matching technology
and they will notify qualified
candidates who have submitted their
resumes to the zip recruiter system when
you post your job and that's why most
employers 80% of employers who post a
job on zip recruiter receive inquiries
from qualified candidates within the
first 24 hours no juggling emails or
calls you use the zip recruiter
dashboard it is the smartest way to hire
and you can find out today for free
why zip recruiter has been used by
businesses of all sizes to find the most
qualified candidates with immediate
results you can post your job for free
at zip recruiter dot-com / Pakman that's
zip recruiter comm slash PA que ma n you
can try zip recruiter for free at zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman